ờ không biết mấy ông có nghe tiếng n s
không à Chắc để tôi tạm tắt tiếng đ
Ờ Nếu mấy ông để ý đúng là cà tôi càng
đang hơi bị à à livestream Muộn
hơn chị thim mượn hơn này thì à đương
nhiên là do gần đây đúng có nhiều
cái gọi là nhiều thứ xảy ra nên là Thành
A tôi là chuyện muộn hơn bình thường và
tôi cũng đang cân nhắc về
vụ có thể nó sẽ ảnh hưởng đến cái việc
livestream thường xuyên này nữa bởi vì à
Kiểu Dạ
nhà thì bây giờ đi làm cả ngày xong rồi
xong rồi đi dậy cả ngày và tôi đang định
như tôi bảo là có dự định kiểu đi học
thêm một cái gì đó
nữa tôi còn đang suy nghĩ là kiểu Nếu
thế thì không biết cái thời gian để mà
mình dành cho bản thân là vào vào lúc
nào đương nhiên là tôi
có tươ nh là tôi có dành một ngày chủ
nhật là một ngày kiểu xả theo kiểu là
không làm cái gì khác ngoài việc là cũng
chẳng gặp ai cả code đ để mà kiểu dành
hoàn toàn cho bản thân nên tôi cảm thấy
là mấy ngày trong tuần th nó vẫn là chưa
đủ Ừ còn phải dành cho các mối quan hệ
khác nữa đúng không ạ Nên tôi đang cân
nhắc tôi đang cân nhắc việc à gì
nhở Có thể livestream ít lại hoặc là như
nào Đấy Hiện tại thì cũng chưa có lịch
gì rõ ràng nhưng mà chắc là tôi nếu mà
tôi đăng ký tôi đăng ký kiểu đi học thêm
cái gì đó ví dụ luyện thanh nhạc hay cái
gì gì đó nữa đúng là khó thời gian là
kiểu ngồi tâm sự chia sẻ mấy ông suốt
được nhưng không sao cứ chước mắt đã
đúng không ạ Có gì tôi sẽ thông báo Mấy
ông cụ thể về lịch mọi thứ sau vì Đúng
là gần đây thì cũng hơi lười để tối có
thể ngồi cốt các thứ nữa vì rõ ràng là
cả ngày đi làm thì kiểu tối ngại phải
động não ấy m không hiểu Tôi không ạ
Nhưng hôm nay tôi vẫn sẽ à tấm sự rồi
tôi sẽ xóa hết sau nhá Hôm nay tôi sẽ
hướng dẫn cho
tôi sẽ chia sẻ cho mấy ông này mấy cái
hay hay này trước đã xong
link này để mà tôi đăng nhập vào
đã đương nhiên là mấy cá
[âm nhạc]
mấy ông đang xem không không bấm vào
được đây để tôi để tôi thể link
hả mic Hình như là vừa tự động bị chỉnh
mấy ông nghe nghe thấy gì không ạ Mấy
ông nghe rõ
không Nếu mà Mấy ông có vấn đề gì Mic
thì báo tôi nhá thì tôi đôi khi không để
ý lắm
ông thấy Mic kiểu bị bé hay gì đấy cứ
bảo nha th ra mic Tôi có thể to to hết
cỡ nhưng mà nó sẽ có dính cả Tặc âm nên
là thành ra
đây đúng không Alo alo alo alo Al
Alo Đúng không ha mic đang dùng mic của
alo thc ra mic này tôi hồi trước mọi khi
nó màu đỏ Lò cơ không biết được là nó
đang đang dùng cái nào đợ đợi tôi một tí
Đợi tôi một
tí
input input defile
này microphone rồi này Alo Alo Đấy đ l
rồi ok
ạ
link này cái này ai Tôi Kiểu cái đoạn
hội đại chat Giữa tôi với chat TVT để
cho mấy ông xem
sau nó làm vẫn khá là sơ
trên nhá
Đây cái này liên quan đến bên công ty
tôi làm là kết nối đến đây kết nối đến
api bên thứ ba nhưng viết theo kiểu mô
hình op thì các thứ thứ như nào đấy
thì tôi nhờ chvt để mà vẽ ra sơ đồ sơ đồ
thực thể cụ thể là sơ Nó là uml thì phải
theo kiểu là là để
mà nói qua về kiểu nên vẽ layer Như như
nào các thứ thứ viết theo hướng đối
tượng oop như nào thì có vẻ nó vẽ vẫn
gọi là nó quen kiểu vẽ kiểu dạng như này
gọi gì à mô hình à không biết được lúc
này còn đỡ hơn một tí này nế là quen
kiểu như này nó không nó không vẽ được
một cái kiểu dạng như là
và tôi phải dùng từ như nào đơn giản hay
là vẽ kiểu dạng mình muốn muốn thấy
Chắc về sau tôi bảo nó liệt kê theo kiểu
là tên file các thứ thứ sẽ ổn hơn chứ
còn cái kiểu kia thì không ổn này Đấy
một cái này n một cái nữa là cái này
thằng này ơ đoạn hộn TH hái Tôi nhớ là
dài hơn cơ
thử hỏi nó những cái câu ví dụ Giả sử
Giả sử là ờ
đây nếu mà We In trong cái danh sách
kiểu ID 1 2 và 9599
đấy nhưng nhưng mà nhưng mà giả sử là
tối đa bản ghi ở trong database chỉ có
100 thôi chẳng hạn thì liệu nó cái đến
cái đoạn mà 999 nó có phản hồi về nhanh
hay hơn hay không kiểu nó xác định rõ là
kiểu kiểu 999 nó không tồn tại thì nó có
phản hồi về nhanh hơn không hay là nó
vẫn phải diệt qua kiểu Index các thứ các
thứ nữa thì câu trả lời của cái thang
này thì nó là
đây có nhanh hơn à và lẫn cả sử dụng
Limit thì sao ví dụ có một bài toán ở
đây nó là như này như th này nhá ví dụ
tôi We In trong cái ID là 12 và 999 này
đúng không mà bản chất là ID nó chỉ đến
100 đấy Và tôi thực tế thực tế là là 1 2
chắc chắn nó sẽ được duyệt rồi và bây
giờ nếu mà tôi Limit 2 thôi chẳng hạn
thì rõ ràng là nó chỉ cần duyệt cái
thằng một cái thằng hai và bỏ qua thằng
9599 và phản hồi về nhanh hơn đúng không
ạ
in 12 9599 My ID chỉ đến 100 thì khi sử
dụng Limit thì nhanh hơn thế nào kiểu K
Thế có nhanh hơn không hay là nó vẫn thế
và kết quả của thằng chity trả lời thì
đó là mình nếu mà mình có dùng thêm
Limit nữa thì nó sẽ còn nhanh hơn nữa
Tức tức là sao nghĩa là rất nhiều rất
nhiều lúc trong trường hợp mà các bạn
kiểu We các thứ các thứ các bạn nên tận
dụng thêm cả Limit nữa để cho cái câu
truy vấn mình có thể nhanh hơn nếu có
thể nếu có thể các bạn xác định rõ được
là là bạn chỉ cần lấy được một số lượng
vừa đủ là bao nhiêu các bạn là ngoài
việc là các bạn We có sử dụng Index ra
thì các bạn nên sử dụng cả Limit nữa thì
tốc hộ nhanh hơn rất nhiều
đây đây tôi còn hỏi ví dụ là giới hạn
đang là 100 nên khi We 9999 thì DB sẽ
phản hồi lại nhanh là không tìm thấy bản
ghi hay vẫn vẫn kiểu vẫn quét luôn cả
bảng để tìm ấy ý ý tôi là kiểu nó có
duyệt qua Index đúng không Nhưng mà nó
phải có lưu cái nó có lưu cái tối đa của
cái kiểu cái con số kiểu cao nhất Nó
hiện tại đang là gì không Nếu mà có thì
nó chỉ cần ví dụ giả sử nó xác định được
999 nó không nằm Tro cho con số nó lớn
hơn con số Tuế Đa đấy thì nó phản hối về
nhanh chứ không phải nó ngồi quét kiểu
full
phun à trong trường hợp này nó sử dụng
Index nên là phun không phải full thê B
nhưng mà nó cũng phải full cả cái
Index đương thì trong này nó có lý giải
đó là À bởi vì là Index trong một vài
trường hợp sử dụng theo kiểu
P là kiểu dạng là kiểu nó n là giống
kiểu
B tr nó viết tắt của binary tr là cây
nhị phân ấy nên là thực ra là nó không
hẳn nó duyệt cả cái toàn bộ Index mà nó
kiểu Tôi chẳng biết mô tả với mấy ông
như nào nữa nhưng đại khái thì nó tôi
nhớ không lầm th Nó là kiểu dạng như
hình dung nhé
chắn lắ đâu Ví dụ bình thường Bình
thường mấy ông nghĩ là sẽ có một 2 3
kiểu như này kiểu Bởi vì bởi
vì primary primary key của mình thường
trong bảng sẽ là cluster Index nghĩa là
là là kiểu giá trị nó sẽ được sắp xếp và
theo kiểu sắp xếp theo có quy luật tức
cả tăng dần hay giảm dần gì không nhớ
lắm nhưng mà đại khái ví dụ Giả sử đây
tăng dần chẳng hạn thì idid đây 1 2 3
đúng không đấy cho cho cho đến 100 nhá
kiểu như này giả sử cho 100 như này chữ
hơ s thông cảm
Nó là kiểu Index mình đang lưu như này
nhưng không th ra bản chất là nó sẽ lưu
theo kiểu là nhánh kể Nó là kiểu nhánh
kiểu như
này hơi sâu tí thông cảm này kiểu 1 ha
này và cho đến 100 này kiểu như này và
khi mà ông ông kiểu ông gọi như nh
ông nhập vào cái kiểu giá trị nào ấy thì
nó sẽ kiểu đi đến cái nhánh cây tương
ứng để mà Bởi vì cái nhánh này sẽ có
nhánh nhỏ hơn nữa các thứ thứ nữa cái ID
1 này nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ trực tiếp đến cái
thằng
nào Đây là cái giá trị lưu Index của ông
nhá xong rồi nó sẽ trò lên tiếp cái bản
ghi các thứ thứ tương ứng Tôi nhớ Tôi
nhớ là có người từng vẽ như thế không
nhớ chính xác lắm Ờ nhưng mà đại khái nó
là thế nên là thành ra là kiểu cho dù kể
cả cho dù tôi nhập và 9599 rõ ràng là nó
Không nó kiểu lớn hơn so với cái tối đa
tối tối đa thì nó vẫn nó vẫn sẽ Tuy là
nó không Duyệt hết toàn bộ mấy cái Index
Nhưng bản chất nó vẫn sẽ cố đi tìm cái
nhánh cây 9599 và không tìm thấy thì nó
sẽ thông báo về kiểu thế nghĩa là nghĩa
là ý tôi ý tôi đó là kể cả là số không
nằm trong cái nhánh cây này cho đến số
nằm trong nhánh cây này thì tốc độ duyệt
của nó cũng ngang nhau đấy Kiểu
thế chứ không phải như ý ý của mình là ý
của tôi lúc đầu tôi hiểu đang hiểu Hồi
trước cũng hiểu Nó là kiểu ví dụ ở Giả
sử tôi có một loạt ID như th này từ 1
cho đến 100 như này hiệ nhiên khi mà tôi
qu We 9999 thì nó sẽ phản hồi nhanh hơn
nó sẽ không phải nó sẽ phải nó không
phải ngồi kiểm tra 9599 này có phải bằng
1 hay không 959 phải bằng 2 hay không 99
phải bằng 3 hay không cứ thế thế cho đến
100 sau đó mới phản hồi là không tìm
thấy 9599 Không không phải cái cách làm
việc của Index nó không phải như thế đấy
là với cây Nhự
phân mày không hiểu V tôi không hiểu hãy
nói tôi hiểu một tí gì đó đi
khó của về Index các thứ thứ
kiểu mới nghe bây giờ bắt đầu nghe nên
nên là có thể không hiểu lắm nhưng mà
Ừ đây X tôi còn hỏi về hệ cơ sở dữ liệu
đây hệ cơ sở liệu chứ không phải một cơ
sở dữ liệu cơ sở liệu thì
ờ cơ sở Liệu mình nó khác với hệ cơ sở
Liệu mình là database mà đúng không
nhưng mà hệ cơ sở liệu nó sẽ là kiểu
dạng như là My SQL này hay là SQL Server
này hay là press hay Vân Vân à đâu hệ
quản trị t đầy đủ như thế thì thì mỗi
thằng nó sẽ có cách xử lý khác nhau
nhưng mà thường là sẽ có một cái trình
tự như này đó là nhận nhận truy vấn này
xong rồi phân tích cú pháp là Sửa lỗi CH
kiểu thông báo lại nếu mà có lỗi cú pháp
về chính tả hay các thứ các thứ đấy x
tiếp theo là tối ưu hóa tối ưu hóa này
nó sẽ đấy bao gồm việc kiểm tra xem là
inex nào được sử dụng và và đưa ra quyết
định là nên nên làm gì Ví dụ là nên quét
cả bạc hay là nên quét Index r tìm để
tìm được dữ liệu xong rồi Từ đấy chọc
vào bản vân vân đấy thì cái này nếu mà
ông dùng cái explain trong select ấy thì
thì ông sẽ biết được là nó sử dụng nó sẽ
chọn cái phương pháp giải pháp nào Ví dụ
cứ hình dung về việc là là đường từ nhà
ông đến công ty đi ho từ nhà ông đến
trường thì có có thể có nhiều đường ý
thì nó thường là nó sẽ cố chọn con đường
đi tội
à Nó có khái niệm là con đường đi Ờ tôi
nhớ không lầm là con đường đi ngắn nhất
kiểu gọi là nhanh nhất nhất ấy nhưng
nhưng đôi khi là nó sẽ nó sẽ bị nặng về
à dung lượng bộ nhớ Tôi nhớ không lầm là
thằng thằng này nó cái thằng hệ quản trị
cơ sở liệu nó thường mang thên hướng như
thế nó sẽ cố luôn tìm được đường đi nhắn
ngắn
nhất nhưng mà nó sẽ bị nặng nên đôi khi
mấy ông về sau mấy ông phải explain để
cân nhắc xem việc nó duyệt qua bao nhiêu
bản ghi và nó tốn dung lượng như nào các
thứ để mình tìm giải pháp T ưu các thứ
tiếp theo nó thực thi câu truy vấn và
trả về kết quả thì thì tôi hồi trước tôi
đọc một cái để mà khiến cho gọi là cái
truy vấn mình chạy nhanh hơn ấy thì một
là câu truy vấn mình có thể ngắn gọn hơn
và đã được phân tích cú pháp trước nó có
thể là đấy do mà các
à Đó lý do các bạn có thể là hồi trước
tôi có dạy cho mấy ông về việc là sử
dụng sử dụng function hay là view thì nó
là là câu truy vấn vừa ngắn gọn và cái
đấy nó đã được lưu lại trong DB rồi nên
thành ra khi mình khi mình gọi nó ra thì
nó gần như không phân tích về cú pháp
nữa thứ thứ thì hai cái bước này à bước
hai bước này nó được tối ưu thêm
đấy xong lý thuyết rồi kiếm vẻ cây khó
hay hay gặp trong thực tế khi truy vấn
xây dựng DB á Ừ tôi khi nào mà có một
cái cụ thể thì tôi sẽ chia sẻ mới ông ví
dụ trong trường hợp này tôi vừa chia sẻ
được việc là mình nên tối u khi khi mà
mình tối ưu kể cả sử dụng Index parik
rồi h thi thì mình có thể dùng lên thêm
Limit Nếu có thể nếu có thể biết trước
thì mình nên dùng thêm Limit mình đừng
có cậy là que theo cái prim key này
nhanh ngắm rồi đấy chứ còn vài trường
hợp nữa thì à Để xem nào ở trên công ty
hôm trước Hình như là tôi cũng mới chia
sẻ mấy ông về vụ là dùng join các thứ
thứ rồi Nói chung là khi nào tôi gặp
những cái cây nà dị nó làm ảnh hưởng khá
nhiều thì tôi sẽ chia sẻ được thêm mấy
ông tôi có hỏi thêm về vụ này với thằng
SQL Server tôi tôi nhớ với thằng sq
server nó nó hồi trước tôi đọc thì nó
đương nhiên là thằng fq server nó thằng
mất phí fq server Đúng không nhỉ Tôi
thường ngy gọi thế không biết là gọi
thấy chuẩn hay
không Ừ đầy đủ nó là Microsoft SQL
Server m SQL thì ra Ừ tôi toàn kiểu đọc
một trong hai kiểu này không sao cứ cho
gọi equ server viết tắt nhá thì à Thì
thằng đấy nó có luôn có nó thằng mất phí
và luôn có kiểu thêm một vài cái cơ chế
riêng một vài tính năng nữa so với thằng
Maria hay là ma Tôi cảm thấy thế
đấy ví dụ là cái quay cách này của nó
này quay cách của này của nó nó tôi nhớ
là nó còn có vài cái nó có
sẵn kiểu dạng là
Ờ dùng bộ như tạm hay dùng cái cách tạm
hay gì đấy Nói chung là khi mà ông truy
vấn một cái gì đó rồi
kể cả kể cả cho dù dữ liệu có thay đổi
nhá Nhưng mà ông select lại đúng cái câu
truy vấn giống hệ thế thì thì nó đã thì
nó nó đã bỏ qua cái bước phân à tối ưu
hóa câu truy vấn này và sử dụng luôn
Chính cái ví dụ tôi tôi tra Google Map
từ nhà tôi lên công ty chẳng hạn đúng
không Thì nó Thì nó phải mất cái khoảng
thời gian để tính toán xem là đường đi
nào nhanh nhất đúng chứ
khi mà tôi tra lại một phát nữa giống
hệt Thế thì nó không tính toán nữa nó
dùng luôn kết quả kiểu đường đi trước
đấy luôn đấy thì coi như là cái phần đấy
nó cũng gọi là gọi là kiểu cách được lại
cái đoạn đoạn kiểu tối ưu này các thứ
các thứ sử dụng lại nên là nó khá là
nhanh đấy đôi khi là đây mấy ông thấy có
tận năm bước này năm bước này ông tối ưu
được cái bước nào thì cái câu ch vấn của
ông sẽ còn nhanh hơn một tí bởi vì đôi
khi cái Thược thi truy vấn nó nó nó là
cái thứ mà kiểu mình tối ưu tối ưu hết
cỡ rồi nó cũng chỉ nh thế và những cái
khác nó lặp đi lập lại ví dụ là cái
cái ví dụ là cái kiểu cách lại cái việc
phân tích và tìm đường đi này đôi khi
mình cách được thì nó sẽ rất là nhanh
hoặc là về sau mình hạn chế select sa
select sao thì nó sẽ trả về tất cả Kết
quả nó sẽ bị nặng đấy mình sẽ phải
select cái gì cái những cái trường mình
cụ thể mình cần select thôi thì nó sẽ
nhẹ hơn bớt đi được đấy nghĩa là một một
vài cái kiểu như thế trong này
khá là hay này prepair statement này là
kiểu đây mấy ông thấy không có thể lưu
trữ kế hoạch thực thi đây chính Kế hoạch
thực thi là cái đoạn mà mà thực thi à
tối ưu hóa cái tr vấn này nó sẽ tìm được
cái tìm đ tìm được cái kế hoạch thực thi
phù hợp nhất này này đấy thì khi mà mình
sử dụng vì để tôi ví dụ mấy ông dễ hình
dung nhá ví dụ Giả sử tôi có select
sound form sinh viên chẳng hạn đúng
không ạ We này ID vàng 10 đúng không ạ
khi mà tôi chạy câu lệnh này thì đương
nhiên nó sẽ chả về rất là nhanh theo
kiểu là Ừ thì ID là primary key nên
thành ra là kiểu nó sẽ sử dụng Index này
trả về nhanh nhưng mà nó có thể nhanh
hơn nữa nếu như vừa nãy tôi có nói đề
cập đó là mấy ông đừng có cậy là primary
Key là sử dụng Index thì chạy nhanh rồi
mấy ông biết thừa là rõ ràng ở đây nó
chỉ trả về một bản ghi Thôi thì tại sao
thêm Limit 1 nữa nó sẽ nó sẽ tìm được
bản ghi đầu tiên tìm thấy rồi phản hồi
về ngay thay vì nó phải ngồi quét cả cả
bả hay gì gì đó để mà
tìm kiểu Tìm tiếp đúng không ạ Đấy nhưng
mà tôi cảm thấy thế này nó vẫn lâu vẫn
lâu ở dại sao ví dụ Giả sử cứ mất 0,01
giây đi đúng không ạ Mà rõ ràng mà rõ
ràng là như tôi vừa nói đề cập đó là nếu
là cho dù câu đấy có thể là nó rất nhanh
rất ngắn gọn đúng không cú pháp đơn giản
Mọi thứ rồi nhưng nó vẫn phải luôn Chạy
lại mỗi khi chạy là coi như là nó lại
phải đi tìm
ạ Không primary key bản chất là nó nó
vẫn Tuy là nó sử dụng Index tôi có đề
cập thì bản chất là nếu mà ông thêm
Limit vào nó vẫn nhanh hơn vừa nãy tôi
có đề cập rồi đấy nghĩa là nó bản chất
nó vẫn quét nó vẫn quét thêm gọn như
này nghĩa là nó tìm được một bản ghi rồi
đúng không
nhưng mà nó vẫn quét quét tiếp vào trong
Index để kiểu nói chung là lấy lấy thêm
giá trị đúng không
Đây Tôi có ghi ở
đây
thôi bản chất
là
này khi đến giá trị thì vẫn sẽ kiểm tra
trong Index đương nhiên là trả về rất
nhanh do cách tổ chức của Index đúng
không đ Xem nà đợi đợi đợi đợi tôi một
tí Ừ nó primary key à Nó là B nên có thể
là nó sẽ phản hồi nhanh nó không phải
duyệt cả cái cả cái
và nó vốn vẫn
unix Nhưng mà thêm Limit và vẫn nhanh
hơn Đúng nhỉ Bây giờ mình thử cứ thử ví
dụ đi đôi khi là mình phải chạy một cái
gì đó test thử đúng không ạ Đây để tôi
tôi thử ví dụ cho mấy ông nhé Tôi nhớ lý
thuyết là thế Có thể tôi
đợi th tí tôi phải mở code
lên tôi phải mở code lên để mà chạy demo
đợi tôi tí Đợi tôi tí nhá Tôi sẽ
chạy bây giờ tôi kết nối thử
lên database của
database của máy
tí cũng hay đôi khi là mình sẽ kiểu mình
mình thảo luận thấy có cái gì không ổn
mình mình làm
luôn mình không không không nên mỗi lý
thuyết xuông đúng không ạ Chúng ta sẽ
nói chuyện với nhau bằng kiểu
thực
tế
Ờ anh ơi cho hỏi đơn giả à Ông kia trả
lời đơn
[âm nhạc]
thì thực ra là kiểu in là cũng đủ 2 tỷ
rồi và mình cũng không bị lẻ lẻ Còn
trong trường hợp mà em muốn lưu kiểu
dạng là
đề cập thì ở
à ở công ty anh thì có lưu kiểu flash
thứ nhất là bởi vì nó trên 2 tỷ và muốn
lưu kiểu thập phân nhưng hồi trước anh
nhớ là có cái vụ lỗi về thập phân cũng
như
là lỗi về thập phân cũng như là kiểu
dạng nh nà
Ừ bởi vì mặc định khi đối đặc biệt với
larel thì phải ờ Hồi đấy khi mà tôi ghi
flash nhưng mà kiểu không không truyền
thêm cái tham số thứ hai vào ấy nên là
thành ra nó chỉ có hai hay ba dấu phẩy
đằng sau ấy s về sau bị lỗi gì gì đó nên
Nếu có thể thì như bạn kia đề cập thì
thực ra lưu kiểu in cũng được theo kiểu
là mình lưu dạng sen Mình lưu lại nói
chung là lưu lại theo kiểu là không có
thập phân thì cũng hay không làm tròn số
nó sẽ kiểu không làm tròn số ấy thì về
sau thống kê nó sẽ không bị sai số
Nhưng mà nếu mà kiểu in đấy thì mình sẽ
phải lưu kiểu BIG in Tức là mình sẽ lưu
hơn 2 tỷ Giả sử thế trong đề phòng ví
sau mình làm mình phí sau có cái đơn nào
hơn 2 tỷ cho dù tôi chưa Chắc về vụ đấy
lắm
Ờ đây để tôi thử tạo database nhá Tạo
một cái database đi Ờ
test Rồi tôi tạo
bảng này bảng sinh viên có ID này kiểu
in này
auto increment đúng không ạ Đâu lắm
không gõ lại
này không vaa là nó lưu lại nặng hơn nữa
cả là mình Hình như là dùng m cái hàm
xăm các th thứ hình như bị lỗi hay gì gì
đó ấy bị lỗi đấy Đừng có làm kiểu
đấy
thấy kiểu nó trong này có nhiều dữ liệu
hơn Ờ đấy chỉ đế Dạ này
này share only Ờ quên quên quên primary
key
ID
ta sẽ ngồi xem dp mình làm đây tôi có
một dp test này cái này tôi đang dùng
tôi chưa Tạo một cái dự án riêng nên tôi
dùng của công
[âm nhạc]
đã add controller
này TH có một
viên mình sẽ
Ờ for mình chạy vòng lặp for đúng không
y
bằng
[âm nhạc]
Insert 10 triệu bản ghi nhá Ờ để xem
viết nó nhanh
đ Tôi muốn Insert 10 triệu Bạn ghi vào
bảng này viết dạng
tôi kiểu như
này
Ờ nếu
mà ừ Insert một lần này Nhưng mà thực tế
là đúng rồi phải có một cái trăng sai
chứ chứ không thì 10 triệu này này một
phát chết luôn DB
đấy đấy đến tầm cái ngưỡng ở đó rồi mình
Insert lại là mới mà Ok Thế là chuẩn
này tầm 500 bản ghi thôi thường là có
thể 500 Thực ra hơi nhiều à hơi ít Tôi
có thể tăng lên là là kiểu dạng Tôi nhớ
là 10.000
quá gì đó tôi sẽ à thực tại sao tôi
không cho cái cột name mà default luôn
PH
xong rồi name ở đây tôi cho default đi
để đỡ phải điền cái này tôi
code à Vẫn phải điền chứ nhỉ Nếu mà
muốn muốn có giá trị
này random này à n thế tôi để name là đ
giạn trẻ A thôi này chạy
này Ok chạy thử
rồi biết chạy được không
phải viết ở đây là
xóa cái config
Ờ đang có
nhỉ Hay là nó không đếm nữa
à Dùng V code rồi à Ừ anh đây anh gọi là
muốn thử mọi cái
mới kiểu dạng là mình đâu Trong trong
lúc đợi nó ngồi chạy
triệu bản ghi thì à Tôi sẽ tranh thủ trả
lời một vài câu hỏi được không
ạ
ạ Không chắc là em chắc anh không là ba
n không khó mà trả lời câu này chắc là
em kiểu H nhở
Ồ anh nghĩ tốt nhất là em
cái thứ anh thể giúp được là em học SQL
các thứ thứ này này sẽ cải thiện phần
nào đấy form sinh viên
Thử
đây tốc độ Chắc là vẫn nhanh
thôi 0,00 giây Thực ra khó để mà kiểu 1
triệu nó vẫn chưa là gì cả và tôi nghĩ
là primary key thì nó sẽ rất là nhanh
[âm nhạc]
Ừ Nên là nếu mà thêm Limit nữa nữa xem
nhanh hơn không
nhá Cái này khó mà xác định được qua cái
này
nay vẫn Nhanh
chưa qua đấy học Em vẫn Nhanh
nhở Xem Insert được bao nhiêu rồi
nhỉ
cao sound
này from sinh viên
này ơ bị kẹp phím rồi đến lúc chuẩn bị
thay phím mới rồi 3
thực chất là nó là máy queo anh đ dùng
má queo Ờ cái phần mềm để kết nối thôi
Còn cái My shop SQL thì thực ra
là s các bạn đều chỉ cần học SQL Nói
chung thôi rồi các bạn nhảy sang m cái
này n thấy đều na ná hết giống hệt nhau
không được không em kiểu Java như là học
sang Android được mà Hồi trước anh cũng
học Android bằng kiểu từ Java các
thứ em đang làm cái dation thì những cái
bên MQ hay oracle h chc những câu quay
cho vấn tối u nhỉ
sq server tôi thấy là kiểu nhiều bên
dùng kiểu proced ấ kiểu thế Thực ra là
tôi vẫn không khuyến khích việc là có
kiểu mình nên xử lý logic ở trong
database Nhưng mà tôi thấy có rất nhiều
bên vẫn còn đang dùng kiểu như thế Lưu
lại lưu lại kiểu à procedure Xong gọi
đến nó ừ thì mấy cái kiểu như thế nó sẽ
truy vấn cảm thấy là tôi thấy try truy
vấn Chắc chắn là nó sẽ tố ưu và nhanh
này tôi thấy vẫn nhanh nh vèo
là trường hợp này này bạn kia nói đúng
nghĩa là cái này Thực ra Nó kiểu nó nó
duyệt qua nó vẫn rất là nhanh rồi vì bản
chất là nó primary
key Ơ đợi tí đợi tí à hình như nó ming
rồi Ừ đợi tôi đây nó diệt qua ky l chỉ
Ngần này thôi nế thành ra là kiểu Limit
Limit kiểu l thêm Limit 1 thì chắc là nó
cũng không kiểu nó gọi nhỉ nó cũng không
cải thiện gì cả
Ừ cái này hay còn nếu mà trong in thì
chắc là nó sẽ khác ví dụ là in kiểu như
này thì nếu mà Limit được thì mình có
thể Limit đúng không
ạ Đấy ví dụ là kiểu như này chẳng
hạn thì nó là cái khác đúng không high
row cái này đương nhiên là tốc độ thì
tôi thấy là thực ra đ ngang nhau kiểu
prim key mà nên là thằng ra nó cũng rất
là
nhanh đây Cái này không không hiển thị
được số dây n cũng không không thể đánh
giá được cái việc là như nào Nhưng mà có
vẻ theo primary key nhanh khó mà xem
được rồi ok 10 triệu nó vẫn chưa là một
cái gì
đó 7 triệu bản gar rồi này như là tốc độ
Đúng là kiểu binary key PR của primary
key n là nó vẫn nhanh quá chẳng thấy gì
cả à
khó khi mà đi làm thực tế ạ Ờ đương
nhiên là đi làm thì chắc chắn là nhiều
lúc bạn cũng kiểu sẽ gặp rất nhiều vấn
đề không phải về V mỗi vấn đề trong công
việc mà đôi khi là kiểu mình làm việc
con người con người với nhau mà nên chắc
chắn là đôi khi là
sẽ sẽ đôi khi là thậm chí trong một vài
trường hợp Tôi cảm thấy là làm việc với
con người còn khó hơn làm việc về máy
tính Chẳng hạn máy móc chẳng hạn đấy nên
tôi cảm thấy là về sao khó mà kiểu làm
quản lý được vì thấy con người rất phức
tạp đấy
thì thường là tôi sẽ biết tôi có một vài
người gọi là tiền bối những cái người mà
tôi cảm thấy tin tưởng thậm chí là xếp
của của tôi luôn đấy là tôi sẽ hỏi trực
tiếp mấy người đấy Kiểu để đưa lời
khuyên góp ý các thứ đươ nhiên là mình
cũng sẽ phải có chính kiến riêng Đưa lời
họ đưa lời khuyên một chuyện mình vẫn
phải tự làm các thứ các thứ tự đưa ra
quyết định đúng không ạ
Và và Gần đây tôi cày tôi càng cải thiện
hơn về cái tư duy Nếu mấy Ông cảm thấy
thế mấy ông cảm nhận được thì tôi cũng
thay đổi rất nhiều tư duy Vì kiểu xếp
Tôi khuyên vài cái ví dụ như
là
đôi khi là có nhiều cái mình cứ Đôi khi
mình cứ nghĩ nó to to lớn ấy vĩ đại kiểu
phức tạp lên ấy mình phải nghĩ đơn giản
hơn và mình phải nhìn vào cái cốt lõi
các thứ thứ của nó nghe nó kiểu bị lý
thuyết đúng không Nhưng mà có rất nhiều
cái ví dụ điển hình việc là là hôm trước
tôi Thỉnh thoảng tôi có tâm sự mấy ông
thì chắc mấy ông mấy ông xem cái đấy mấy
ông sẽ dễ hình dung hơn trường hợp bây
gi tôi phải nhớ hết các trường hợp Phả
nhớ việc
là tôi phải nhớ là sếp tôi thường hay
Khuyên Khuyên nhiều đấy Tôi áp dụng được
một vài cái ví dụ nhá ví dụ một cái Điển
hình mà tôi hay nhớ đó là đôi khi ông
ông đã định nói cái gì đó hoặc ô đang
định làm gì đó sợ ông Quên đúng không ạ
sợ ông cố nhớ cố nhớ bằng được cái đấy
đúng không ạ thì sếp tôi thường có những
lời khuyên để cho sếp kiểu gọi là bớt
đau đầu đó là kiểu là Nếu mà thực sự nó
quan trọng như thế thì kiểu gì em sẽ nhớ
ra để em làm Còn nếu mà em quên rồi và
em cảm thấy mãi em không nhớ ra chứng tỏ
nó nó không quan trọng đ như em nghĩ
thực ạ Không phải cố nhớ nó làm gì cả
đấy Đấy là một cái lời khuyên cảm thấy
rất là đơn giản khiến ch mình cũng nhẹ
đầu bớt đi mình không phải cứ ngồi nghĩ
kểu ngồi nhớm mã các thứ các thứ cũng
như là những cái gì mà khó khó quá thì
em phải đi tìm trợ
giúp trợ à và gọi là cái vấn đề nào mà
mình không giải quyết được thì mình phải
đẩy vấn đề đấy cho người nào mà có
chuyên môn có thể giải quyết được chứ
đừng cố ôm nó đấy Đấy là một trong lời
khuyên của Sếp tôi nữa đấy có rất nhiều
cái Đương nhiên cũng thỉnh thoảng gặp
những cái bấc gặp những cái vấn đề rất
là
tôi nốt liên tục vào trong cái to của
tôi này t nốt và liên tục tục cái khác
đấy Đúng rồi
nhưng không không phải nói là chúng ta
kiểu hãy cứ cứ quên được não mình không
nên kiểu như thế nhưng ý tôi là ý của
Sếp của tôi không phải là chỉ là mình cứ
sống kiểu vô ch rồi Kiểu kiểu cứ quên
thế được đúng không ạ ý ý của Sếp tôi đó
là não mình nó cũng sẽ chỉ có giới hạn
của nó thôi mình sẽ chỉ nhớ được một
cách tương đối thôi Đúng là kiểu mình
nên tận dụng là mình nên phải nốt ra đâu
đó khi có thể tôi cũng thường hay nốt
lại mọi thứ không không bao giờ nên phụ
thuộc vào kiểu cậy là Ừ mình sẽ nhớ được
cái vấn đề đấy không mình khi mà mình
nhớ ra mình phải nốt lại luôn
đấy còn nếu mà đột nhiên mình đang định
nói cái gì
đó đang định nói cái gì đó thôi Đang
định làm cái gì đó mà tự nhiên mình quên
có thể nó m chỉ một câu nói đùa hay cái
gì gì đó ha câu để bắt chuyện trong cái
tình huống đấy mà mình quên thì đúng là
có thể nó không quan trọng thật nế là
mình mới kiểu không kiểu mình chỉ nó một
cái Bộc Phát Thôi xong mình lại quên
ngay
mà nhưng mà cái lời khuyên của sếp Tôi
tóm gọn lại ấ Thì đấy là cách làm việc
của Sếp tôi nữa đó là sếp tôi làm mọi
thứ để tối ưu cho công việc còn tất cả
những cái thứ khác thì không quan trọng
đối với sếp tức cả sao nghĩa là khi nói
chuyện ở trên công ty anh ấy nói chuyện
phiếm anh này nói chuyện vô ch vãi
trưởng luôn nói chuyện kểu mấy ông xem
được trên trang cá nhân tôi sẽ thấy kiểu
tôi thường xuyên kiểu bóc cổ anh đấy
à anh nge nói chuyện kiểu kiểu bị khó
chịu ấy đấy
đấy nghĩa là chỉ anh ấy bảo là trong
công việc thì anh sử sử dụng não còn
toàn bộ những cái vấn đề khác thì anh ấy
kiểu không kiểu để não nghỉ ngơi nên
thành ra anh ấy
không không sử dụng não nên nói chuyện
an công nhện nhiều lúc chế thật nhưng mà
Đấy là cách làm việc của Sếp tôi và mình
và mình đôi khi là phải chấp nhận thế đó
là não mình nó có cái giới hạn của nó nó
nên có thời gian nghỉ thì mình những lúc
mà mình cảm thấy là nó quan trọng thì
mình sử dụng não còn những lúc mà mình
kiểu đấy Kiểu cái bình thường th này thì
mình không dùng và và khi mà mình sử
dụng não rồi mà gặp những cái vấn đề rất
là
khó thì mình cũng phải tự đặt cái giới
hạn cho mình đó là chỉ ông ngồi nghiên
cứu cái đấy trong vòng 2i hay 3 tiếng
Chắc chắn là ông không nên bỏ cuộc sớm
đúng không ạ Ông vẫn phải ngồi nghiên
cứu nó đã ông phải xác định rõ là kiểu
giới hạn của nó
tầm tầm hai hay ba tiếng gì đó để để mà
ngồi nghiên cứu tầm đấy hoặc là hơn cũng
được tùy xem cái deadline công việc của
ông như nào Nhưng ông nên báo sớm với
sếp là ông phải luôn báo với sếp là là
em đang gặp vấn đề này cái thứ thứ em sẽ
bỏ thời gian ra để em nghiên cứu nó xong
sau đó thì em sẽ trả lời ví dụ tôi
thường ha Nói chuyệ với sếp tôi này Sếp
tôi thì toàn kiểu cứ gì deadline ấy Tôi
thường gọi sếp bây giờ biến thành cái
máy dục rồi đấy Thế Toàn bảo ủi cái này
đơn giản trong hôm nay xong em nhé hay
là kiểu ngày mai xong em nhé đấy thì tôi
toàn nói là kiểu em sẽ nghiên cứu trong
ngà trong buổi sáng nay chẳng hạn Đầu
giờ chiều nay em sẽ báo cho anh à là dự
kiến bao giờ em có thể xong đấy phải nên
nói một cái gì đó như thế để sếp biết
được à
mình có làm và mình mình kiểu sẽ báo cáo
lại sớm Bởi vì sếp Thực ra là anh em
mình Làm lập trình với nhau thì chắc
chắn cũng hiểu được là mình không thể
hứa hẹn trước được một cái điều gì cả
đương nhiên là sẽ có rất nhiều vấn đề nó
có thể xảy ra đúng không ạ nhưng mình
nhưng mà sếp BN chân sếp là quan tâm
tiến độ và hiệu quả công việc thì hiệu
quả hay không thì chưa biết nhưng mà
tiến độ công việc thì sế phải luôn nắm
được nên nên thành ra là mình phải luôn
bảo cá lại xếp những cái điều đấy Và như
tôi vừa bảo thì khi mà ông gặp một vấn
đề gì khó Ông bỏ một thời gian ra ông
nghiên cứu mà không được ông phải Báo
sớm cho sếp để sếp biết cách để tìm giải
pháp một là đẩy cái công việc khó đấy
cho người nào có chuyên môn cao hơn hay
là trực tiếp giúp đỡ ông vân vân ông
đừng có ngại việc là ông từng ngại việc
kiểu dấu dốt hay các thứ đi làm thì chắc
chắn là mình hạn chế để công việc mình
ảnh hưởng tiến độ đến
đến đến thứ nhất là với sếp trực tiếp
với sếp nếu mà ông không làm xong kịp
thì sếp cũng sẽ bị ảnh bị ảnh hưởng chứ
đâu phải mỗi ông đâu đúng không ạ nên
là có vấn đề gì thì nên nói sớm nên Báo
trước để cho mọi người còn chuẩn bị các
thứ thứ đúng không ạ đương nhiên là khi
mà khi mà sếp mà giao cho ông rất nhiều
cái việc khó thì thứ nhất ông phải cân
nhắc lại việc bảo lại với sếp là kiểu
sếp g em toàn những cái khó khó quá tầm
khả năng của em thì đương nhiên là nghe
cái đấy giống như kiểu Uầy Thế mình có
thể nguy cơ bị đuổi việc hoặc là cái gì
gì đó nhưng mà Đúng là một môi trường mà
ông cảm thấy là ông không thể làm được
một cái gì đó thì ông phải cân nhắc xem
lại ông phải kiểu nghĩ đến việc là mình
à Mình cần phải làm gì đó đúng không
ạ Đấy Nói chung là đấy là lời khuyên của
tôi bây giờ cách xử lý của tôi như thế
ví dụ hôm qua ngay hôm qua thôi tôi cũng
gặp một cái một cái kiểu tác rất là khó
tôi ngồi nghĩ buổi sáng không được thì
tôi buổi chiều tôi kiểu bảo với sếp để
tôi dùng luôn Sếp làm con vịt lập trình
Nếu mấy ông biết kỹ thuật đấy th con vịt
Lập trình là mình
sẽ sẽ kiểu ngồi giải thích K thứ thứ cho
người kia Để người kia để tự mình gọi
như là tự mình hiểu được đúng không đúng
không ạ t tự mình ra được cái vấn đề đấy
Xong rồi tôi tự giải quyết được cái vấn
đề đấy nhưng mà đơn nhiên là sế cũng
phải cop ý các thứ thứ để nó tối ưu hơn
thực ra không phải tối ưu hơn đâu mà để
cho code nó clean hơn tôi thì cứ bị chăm
chăm việc là vừa làm vừa nghĩ việc tối
ưu xong rồi Sếp thì cứ bảo là
à
sếp à thường hay phải à xếp thì thường
hay kiểu cố kìm tôi lại ấ không thì tôi
bị Bay cao quá ấy gọi là overthinking
hay gì gì đó đúng không nghĩ xa vời quá
sếp cố kìm nó lại sếp bà là em nghĩ là
bài toán nó có thể như thế nó có thể bị
nặng như thế nhưng mà em chưa có một con
số gì cụ thể và Mình chưa gặp cái vấn đề
đấy thì tốt nhất là em cứ làm cứ làm sao
cho nó đơn giản hóa bài toán code sao
cho clean đi Ừ thì có thể chấp nhận là
là nó thêm nhiều vòng lặp để xử lý nó có
thể lâu hơn nhưng mình có còn chưa biết
được là nó lâu hơn như thế nào mà đúng
không Tôi thường hay làm tôi thường hay
nghĩ việc tối ưu các thứ thứ để mà cho
code đoạn đấy nó chạy nhanh bởi vì cái
phần Tôi làm nó liên quan đến phần thanh
toán nữa tạo đơn và thanh toán nên tôi
nghĩa là cái đoạn đấy chắc chắn là cần
nhanh các thứ thứ đúng không ạ nhưng mà
sế Phả bảo là đầu tiên là đầu tiên là
mình phải nghĩ đơn giản trước là cho
code chạy được đã đấy tiếp theo là làm
sao cho code clean đã rõ ràng dễ hiểu dễ
sửa sau đó thì nếu về sau có gặp vấn đề
gì đó liên quan đến hiệu năng thì mình
mới đi tìm bài toàn tối ưu chứ đừng có
vừa làm vừa nghĩ tối u thứ nhất mình bị
đau đầu rất nhiều thứ đúng không ạ Đấy
Nói chung
là tôi thường tôi thường hay kể cho mấy
câu chuyện như thế cũng một phần là khoe
tôi GP được đúng Thầy kiểu người khiến
kiểu mình kiểu mình gọi là làm việc mọi
thứ hiu quả hơn cũng như là
khi mà tôi gặp những cái tình huống Thế
thì cách giải quyết của tôi như nào mấy
ông thể tham khảo
Ờ công ty tôi làm về sản phẩm gì ạ công
ty tôi làm về trang thương mạ điện
tử Anh cho em hỏi viết procedure chỉ cho
dba da de mới dùng chứ bác làm thì sao
đến đoạn ý nhỉ đúng thực ra là chuẩn là
predu thì gọi nh proced thường là người
làm liên quan database thì người ta sẽ
là người làm mình sẽ là người gọi đến nó
thôi nhưng mà gọi nhì tôi thấy là tôi
chưa gặp được công ty nào mà mà sử dụng
proced hợp lý ấ nó thường ha kiểu một
ông viết proced ông kia chỉ gọi và xử lý
xử lý logic khá nhiều ở bên trong
database và tôi cảm thấy là nó cứ bị
theo theo như tôi hiểu tôi bảo toàn bộ
những cái tôi chia sẻ mấy ông đều chia
sẻ thật lòng theo cái trình độ của tôi
có thể trình độ tôi không cao siêu gì
lắm nhưng mà theo như tôi hiểu thì bác
en à B ta toàn gọi B nh backend
developer là xử lý code xử lý logic ở
trong code thường là mình nên những cái
bài toán nghiệp vụ mình nên xử lý trong
code ở back end không phải xử lý ở fanel
không phải xử lý ở trong
Ờ trong database theo tôi là như thế chỉ
tập trung hết trong code ở trong backend
thôi
fan nên chỉ làm vụ hiển thị còn database
nên chỉ làm vụ là lấy vài trả về dữ liệu
và đương nhiên là mình nếu mà tận dụng
được vài cái tôi nghĩa về sau cùng lắm
mà làm ấy thì sẽ là làm thêm view để
mình select Từ view vừa liên quan đến
bài toán về bảo mật vừa liên quan đến
việc là là
ờ liên quan đến bài toán là kiểu nó truy
vấn nhanh hơn procedure đương nhiên là
nó cũng sẽ để nó sẽ cũng có bảo mật có
nhưng mà nhiều người kiểu bị lạm dụng
procedure quá nên xử lý rất nhiều cái
nghiệp vụ ở trong procedure thậm chí là
cả cả trong Trigger nữa có công ty tôi
biết là có sử dụng cả Trigger nữa làm
cho kiểu về sau không biết được nào lần
ví dụ Ông ins vào trong một bảng Tự
nhiên thấy mấy bảng khác cũng được cầm
Nhật đấy Kiểu thế ông còn chẳng hiểu tại
sao rõ không tìm thấy một đoạn code nào
đy chỉ vụ đấy Hoa nó nằm rồi Nó lại xử
lý logic ở trong database đấ kiểu thế
thì tôi cảm thấy là nó hơi
nó cái đấy nó là cái gọi là cái mặt tối
à mặt mặt tối của cái việc ờ công ty tôi
tôi thường hay gọi cái khái niệm chung
đấy gọi là chích kiểu dạng chích chích
code tức cả mấy kiểu chích ấy mấy không
biết kiểu chích mẹo hay hiden code à Tôi
chẳng nhớ nữa hoặc là
hiden logic gì gì đó đại khái là kiểu ắ
chỉ là tự nhiên có một cái đoạn code đấy
tồn tại tự nhiên có cái cơ chế đấy tồn
tại mà không thấy nó giải thích ở đâu
không hề đề cập ở trong tài liệu bất kỳ
tài liệu nào đấy Kiểu thế tôi chạy cái
này tự nhiên cái đoạn kia chạy hoặc là
tự nhiên Tôi có một đoạn code này nó
chẳng liên quan trong cái nghiệp vụ gì
cả nhưng tự nhiên nó phải có ở đấy
thì thì nó mới kiểu nó mới đúng
đấy thì à à đại khái là mình hạn chế mấy
cái hiden code này hiden logic này hay
chick code kiểu như này để cho code mình
clean Mình rõ ràng mình người mới người
ta vào người ta có thể đọc được và hiểu
được nghiệp vụ là từ đầu đến cuối mình
làm gì chứ không phải mình mình à kiểu
dạng trích một tí các thứ thứ như
này người người sau người ta còn người
ta mà người ta đọc kỹ tài liệu rồi người
ta cũng không hiểu được tại sao tự nhiên
có đoạn đấy Tại sao tự nhiên logic lại
xử lý như này đúng không
vậy ạ thì công ty tôi vẫn dùng larel với
view View Face Quốc là n n
dùng oraco bao giờ ông lại lượt một là
ông dùng ai hai ông cứ đăng lên hỏi bên
discord chắc là có và có ông nào có dùng
đấy Cho em hỏi database Engine Sắp tới
có nhiều chỗ làm không ạ Ừ vị trí interm
thì rất là khó bởi vì những cái những
cái người mà được động ở DB thì thường
là vẫn nên kiểu dằng là đã từng trải
không không không nên kiểu dạng
là chiều mới lại được động vào database
để dở đúng không ạ Nên là ông nên làm
kiểu thường là tôi thấy là ông thể làm
tester hoặc là da kiểu hoặc là
da gì gì đó Nói chung là chức vụ nhỏ
nhưng mà được động và và databas trước
để mà thực hành chánh hiệm trước là tốt
lắm rồi và chuyên về SQL để động vào các
thứ rồi về sau lên lên dần về sau mới
kiểu đảm nhận được cái to chứ không
Đương nhiên là không công ty nào giờ
tuyển cho một ông interm vào cả cho dù
hôm trước là tôi thấy có một bạn bạn ấy
làm à Bạn ấy làm năng á bạn ấy làm từ
ba da
tester làm nhiều V trưởng vì công ty ấy
kiểu Dạ công ty ấy cậy là công ty ấy
kiểu sale bán hàng tốt ấy và không quan
tâm
đến tch h data data à data Engineer tôi
đọc nhầm thành database
Engineer data Engineer thì thì thực ra
tôi cũng không biết về công việc data
Engineer nó có phải gần giống data analy
không
nhỉ Nhưng là theo Tôi động vào data thì
chắc là chỉ cần SQL là đủ chứ Xong rồi
làm inm
à Tôi chưa gặp bạn nào làm data Engineer
bao giờ để mà để mà cẩu không biết
khuyên ông kiểu gì cũng không biết là
công việc đấy làm những cái gì
license không
đấy thì mấy ông có gì mấy ông inbox trao
đổi nhau kìa hoặc là nhắn đên discord nó
dễ hơn
etl Hình như là etl là
mấy ông cứ hỏi tôi tôi cũng chỉ gọi là
làm tốt trong cái phần của mình thôi chứ
tôi không phải là người người hiểu rộng
thôi Chỉ là người biết sâu về một vài
cái mà mình dành thôi nên là có rất
nhiều cái chịu mấy không hỏi tôi mới
biết à đây extract transform ngĩ là tôi
có nhớ cái vụ này nó nó cũng chỉ là liên
quan đến việc câu select các thứ thứ và
và kiểu xử lý dữ liệu đấy để mà kiểu ra
cái thống kê hay các thứ các thứ đúng
không
cụ các thứ thứ tôi nhớ là
dùng từ Engineer cho chứ không phải
alist là phân tích thì đúng là sẽ sẽ
động đến cả bên gần như là giống đố tức
là kiểu biết về mấy cái kiểu hệ thống
các thứ
thế Tôi không biết thật Chịu mấy ông nói
thì tôi mới biết thôi bây giờ thực ra là
vì cái ngành Công nghệ thông tin này hot
và nhu cầu Nói chung là mọi thứ nó cũng
tách bạch dần ra hơn rồi nên là nên là
kiểu có thêm rất nhiều vị trí nữa TH là
vị trí này lâu rồi nhưng mình th tôi là
kiểu là trước là có kiểu một công ty
thường là sẽ chỉ có một công ty tôi
thường ha làm stup ấy thì chỉ công ty
kiểu bé bé thì nó sẽ chỉ có một vài vị
trí kểu Cùng lắm một ông de ốp kimm luôn
cả phần hệ thống nữa Ờ nhưng mà bây giờ
là cài và tôi chưa làm bên doanh nghiệp
thật chưa Tôi định là về sau nếu làm
doanh nghiệp thì có thể làm bên ft chẳng
hạn Tôi vẫn nhớ cái câu đó là ai rồi
cũng sẽ Ai rồi cũng sẽ làm qua ở ssop
thôi đấy vì sau tôi sẽ làm thử Nếu có
thể thì sẽ làm bên ssop để mà biết qua
về cái nghiệp vụ cách làm việc chuyên
nghiệp cũng như là đấy có thể biết thêm
được các bên bộ phận khác làm những cái
gì Vân vân vân bởi vì một doanh nghiệp
to thì lúc đấy có rất nhiều chức vụ các
thứ đúng không Thực ra mấy cái chức vụ
kia nó còn chỉ mang tính chất tương đối
nữa Tức là mấy cái Tuy là mấy ông bảo là
kiểu vừa rồi bảo đấy taata Engineer thì
làm những cái việc này việc này nhưng mà
đấy là theo quy ước của từng công ty nó
sẽ làm những cái thứ khác
à Tôi Vẫn Nhớ nhớ là một vài nơi thì qa
về QC nó bằng với cả tester luôn nhưng
mà vài nơi thì qa là làm một kiểu QC lại
là một kiểu đấy và tester là một kiểu
tách biệt ra đấy Nên
là nói chung
là nhưng mà đương nhiên mình vẫn phải
nên học hết Nếu mình muốn đi làm F shop
là công ty lớn nhưng mà không phải dự án
nà cũng chuyên nghiệp à Ừ thì tươ nhiên
là mình vẫn phải hiy vọng may mắn
vào Thực ra là chuyên nghiệp về code thì
tôi không rõ nhá Nhưng mà đang nói về
cái thái độ và cái quy trình làm việc
thì tôi nghĩ là doanh nghiệp để tồn tại
thì chắc chắn nó sẽ phải có một cái kiểu
quy trình hay làm việc chuyên nghiệp các
thứ các thứ cò tính ra tôi làm ở công ty
stup này thì mọi thứ nó vẫn tương đối
rất là thoải mái giếng việc chấm công đã
không phải chấm công khá là thoải mái
rồi đấy Kiểu
thử nhưng mà tôi nhở tôi nghĩa là mấy
ông thay vì hỏi tôi mấy ông tạo trên
discord đi ạ rồi anh em mình trao đổi
tôi lúc đấy tôi có thời gian nghiên cứu
rồi sẽ kiểu trao đổi kỹ hơn trên discord
mấy ông biết kênh discord rồi mà đúng
không ạ Đấy tạo THT là tạo th tôi tường
gọi th như th ra tr À đấy kểu thế tạo
Đấy là anh
[âm nhạc]
đâu Cái
riêng của anh ấy còn cái mấy cái bên kia
thì người khác quản lý không
rõ
thôi Hơi giất mình đi Ừ cái này hơi nhạy
nhở
trình học
nhỉ Thực ra hồi trước tôi thường khuyên
mấy ông xem cái Road map này này như th
root map này nó bị nó bị
giải ví dụ là kiểu làm B này à back này
kiểu tôi còn không biết hết ở trong đúng
này kiểu
Engineer Chắc là data scienti không xem
nào
[âm nhạc]
luôn
vbn và thay đổi cái gì ấ Tôi quên mất
rồi như một hay cái gì đó
ơ Facebook bị lỗi à
hai sao tự nhiên thấy không Không có nổi
thông báo
nữa
ơ như Facebook bị lỗi á Đang định sau
cái này ngồi chơi một
tí cờ nhân phẩm nhưng mà T đang nhập
bằng Facebook mà Ủa
Alo ở trên này đợi đợi tôi thử xem qua
nhá Đấy thì nó sẽ là lấy dữ liệu này xử
lý dữ liệu này x phân tích ra để làm
biểu đồ này xong rồi Dự đoán Ừ thì tôi
thấy là cái này tôi cũng hiểu rõ mà vậy
tôi có nói đây bản chất là ông nm rõ vql
này và biết nói chung là biết sử dụng
những tool các th thứ thậm chí là có
biết một tí code để mà xử lý dữ liệu đấy
sử dụng mấy cái tool để mà tạo ra biểu
đồ thứ thứ Nói chung là
cũng theo theo theo lý thuyết là như thế
nhớ là theo lý thuyết là
giác mà kiểu chỉ cần sóng sáu mươi mấy
người xem mà chỉ còn tầm tầm 10 hay mười
mấy người bình luận bình luận
à Nó đã
kiểu không không trả lời được kịp rồi
tôi bắt đầu hiểu nếu mà giả sử phải sau
Làm kiểu mấy anh streamer kiểu
kiểu nghìn người xem cùng lúc thậm chí
cao hơn xong rồi mà bình luận thì chắc
là tôi rất nhiều lúc tôi cảm thấy là kìa
Mấy anh này khó Không không hay để ý
bình luận mà tôi đã hiểu cảm giác đấy
không thể đọc kịp rồi Đang trả lời cái
này nhảy ra cái kia không kéo kéo xuống
đọc thì nó kiểu nó sẽ bị chậm chậm chậm
hơn tiến độ hơn ý vân
vân công ty em đang thự tập có ông Tech
Pro như thiếu kiến thức sư phạm Nên ông
hay chửi bạn
inter sau công ty lội tàn vì do ông hay
chửi đúng đôi khi là kiểu làm thế nên là
xếp tôi khi mà Tuyển một người nào đó
không phải vì mỗi kiến thức chuyên môn
nữa mà phải quan trọng Xem người đấy có
phù hợp với văn hóa công ty hay không
nữa bởi vì à văn hóa công ty rất là quan
trọng Kiểu cái môi trường làm việc nó
phải kiểu không hẳn là dùng từ chuyên
nghiệp đâu mà phải nên gọi nhở Môi
trường đấy phải phù hợp để cho các bạn
thoải mái làm việc
này làm việc được với nhau các thứ thứ
và thì lúc đấy mình mới phát triển được
cái năng lực của bản thân lên mình mới
muốn làm hơn V Giả sử là kể cả do dụ Ông
giỏi đến mấy nhưng mà kiểu do là đồng
nghiệp của ông Tô xích quá vân vân vân
thì ông sẽ không muốn cống hiến đúng
không ạ ông đấy thậm chí Ông còn muốn
kiểu công ty một ông rời công ty hay ông
muốn phá công ty luôn đấy Nên là tốt
nhất là là các sếp phải biết được những
cái phải biết tạo nên cái môi trường làm
việc thoải mái đương nhiên nó rất là khó
vì mỗi người một tính cách r vân vân vân
Thế nên tôi mới bảo là tôi chắc về sau
tôi không hề hợp làm sếp vì mình không
giỏi làm bài toán với con người như thế
Tôi nghĩ là ờ cái việc mà bị đăng suất
hết Như này lại nhớ đến cái hồi trước
cái sự kiện của Facebook bị đang xất một
loạt này là do một ông hacker nào đó
ngồi mò được cái bức rồi lấy được 5
triệu à 5 triệu Token người dùng à Nên
là trong đêm hôm đấy Tất cả mọi tài
khoản bị đăng xuất raia mà cái này nếu
mà tài khoản bị đăng xuất raia kiểu này
tôi nghĩ là cũng có thể thế hoặc là lỗi
code giống như không là vạ nhưng mà lỗi
code này mà lỗi đồng loạt tất cả thì nó
nó nó hơi vô lý vì giống như là tôi thấy
là code thằng thằng Facebook code nó cứ
để nhều lúc đều đều có thể không viết
test à không biết được nhưng mà ý tôi
cái vô lý ở đây đó là là tất cả các tất
cả các tài khoản ấy
mà nó đang không không phải là nó đều
dùng chung một cái mã nguồn code theo
tôi là như thế vì chúng ta có nhiều
người sẽ được thử nghiệm trước tính năng
có người không nên thành ra
là nên nên thành ra là
kiểu chỉ một số người bị thôi và một số
người sẽ không bị chứ không chuyện là
tất cả cùng
nào co dữ liệu từ các trang web
ecommerce không
ạ Thì hôm trước hôm nay tôi định chia sẻ
mấy ông về kiểu kiểu crw các thứ thứ này
này nhưng hôm nay vẻ vẫn chưa kịp thời
gian để mà ngồi ngồi nói này Hôm nay mới
nói được mỗi hai này
này tiêu đề này đại khái thì nó
hết chữ gì không au nó cũng phải đặt
nhiều nơi Chứ vì rõ ràng là là nó có
nhiều server khác nhau Ừ có thể server ở
Việt Nam chết thì cũng là một cái yếu tố
có thể có
hiện này này à Tôi nhớ không lầm Nó là
cái gì
mình cứ ghi tiêu đề này để mình thử trí
nhớ mình phả mình chẳng nhớ được cái gì
quá hả Facebook Vào được
chưa t thử
nhá Messenger còn bị đăng xuất ra rồi
này ồ something qu wrong luôn rồi
nhỉ
Về Facebook
rồi ồ không phải mỗi Việt Nam Đúng không
cả bên nước ngoài
Hai thế
thì thế thì không phải mộ server
out
rồi Mỗi server Out Việt Nam
đống cổ phiếu các thứ à không cổ phiếu
vẫn thế nh mất một đống tiền cái vụ Đôi
khi chỉ mấy cái vụ kiểu như này kiểu một
tiếng hay hai tiếng gì đó là coi như là
à kiểu bay khá nhiều tiền các thứ thứ
đấy ây thấy nhiều người xem mình hơn hẳn
đúng kiểu dạng là kiểu các bạn bị thoát
Facebook qua rồi thêm thêm người
tiktok chẳng
Twitter à Không Bây giờ là x nhở th à TH
có khi bây giờ cũng bị bay rồi nhỉ vì nó
dung chung
mà
có ông nào vào thử tr Xem cò năng nhật
phải không ạ à something r wrong luôn
rồi
nhớ là thằng Tôi nhớ là cái vụ thằng
thằng nào bị tách ra ấy để nó độc lập ấ
Hình như
Messenger và thằng th cũng phải thế nhỉ
Dùng chung nhỉ
chung vào thằng Facebook rồi insta Nó cố
tình gộp chung rồi Ý tôi là Messenger nó
làm tách ra so với
thằng thằng
Facebook còn th thì theo tôi ấ thì chuẩn
là nó phải tách ra chứ thằng th nó sinh
ra làm gần như là nó muốn biến thành cái
mạng xã hội riêng để cạnh tranh với
thằng Twitter cái thằng insta Thì lúc
đầu nó độc lập với Facebook không nói
nhé nhưng mà thằng Facebook về sau mua
lại xong rồi nó đang dần dần bị muốn
kiểu ghép hai thằng với nhau nghĩa là
một nơi chỉ đang ảnh nhưng mà kiểu dạng
kín hơn các thứ thử nhưng còn thằng tred
Đương nhên thằng tred nó cũng là lấy từ
bên insta sang đúng không ạ nhưng mà
theo tôi thì rõ ràng nó vẫn nên độc lập
nghĩa làm chỉ tôi thấy điển hình nhất
của tr là á chỉ ông vẫn thể đăng ký tr
độc lập so với insta thì phải
is down
for everyone or just me
ý xong ngồi tra Facebook
sử dụng cái trống Ok x Facebook down for
everyone đấy nó gợi luôn ng từ đâu
đấy ai cũng báo có thử thử log in này
đấy rất nhiều người
đó đúng không ạ Tải trang Xem đăng ký
à report
Canada đâ nhỉ được xư log in ero reip C
th
tầm Alo trước
đấy share code website Ông kia OK vào
đây Đừng có quảng cáo gì
à tôi nghĩ nếu Giả sử về Sao tôi mở
olifan chắc tôi D lên đấy tôi cũng dạy
học
mất bán khóa premium trên
đấy nó là nào giống như là có có Uầy
lượng người xem lên cao phết Cũng kiểu
dạng
là ra không lướt được Facebook nữa thôi
Ờ cái gì nhở Ờ tôi vẫn nhớ hồi trước có
vài ông còn đăng lên hẳn mấy cái trang
18+ kiểu video dạy học các thứ các thứ
mà xong rồi Ngồi chia sẻ các thứ thứ
trên đấy Xong rồi còn cái quan trọng là
mấy ông ấy đẩy đăng lên là một chuyện có
người xem và người tương tác hả No xong
còn hỏi đáp các thứ thứ trên đấy anh em
lành mạnh phết trên đấy các thứ thứ đỉnh
vãi Có khi là kiểu đấy hay
tảng
các thứ thứ trên mọi nền
năng docker linus Amazon lael xin được
luôn Junio không ạ
các thứ các thứ Người ta cũng sẽ hỏi em
vài câu xem trình độ kiểu lý thuyết em
đến đâu về Junior Junior thực tế là làm
được việc rồi và gọi là chẳng qua chưa
trải sự đời thôi Nên là Junio Thực ra
cũng được fester là chỉ chẳng biết làm
gì cả theo như đánh giá như thế nhưng mà
vẫn thời gian đầu hai tháng thử Việt ho
3 tháng thử việc thì em sẽ biết được
ngay mà em cứ mạnh dạn kiểu ứng tuyển
thôi Còn khi phỏng vấn mà thấy một vài
bên không ổn thì mình sẽ điều chỉnh lại
lúc đấy thậm chí là ngay ở trong lúc
phỏng vấn người ta cũng sẽ xem xét và
điều chỉnh lại
anh kiểm
lậu có có bao giờ về sau mình à không
chắc là về sau mình không bị nick khóa
học lậu đâuu vì rõ ràng là mình
cũng chia sẻ mọi thứ miễn phí mà nhỉ Ừ
nhưng mà ý tôi là kiể V sau có người nói
đăng lại của tôi kiểu các thứ các thứ
nghe kiểu cũng oai ấ kh Chắc là sẽ đến
một ngày nào đó nó là nào giống như là
tôi nhớ hồi trước cái anh streamer nà
tôi xem ấy kiểu hình như anh piu piu à
Hay anh nào
ấy hay là hay
kiểu
là sẽ đến một cái ngưỡng ở đó nổi nỗi là
kiểu sẽ có kiểu bị nick một cái gì gì đó
này xong bị spam kiểu mình con boss gì
đó vào spam vì kênh nó kiểu cũng nhiều
tương tác rồi ấ đủ đủ to rồi ấy đấy Xong
rồi nói chung là đại khái thì có thêm
nhiều thành phần hơn đấy hiện tại thành
phần hiện tại à Hiện tại kiểu những
người đang xem thì đều là những người
kiểu đều là người cả không phải là boss
mà và đều kiểu dạng là tìm đến kênh tôi
theo kiểu là chủ đích nhưng về sau là
khi mà kênh nổi hơn cái thứ thứ về sau
sẽ có một đồng boss vào đây chẳng hạn
và bing gbt bing gbt Hình như là cái này
tôi đang dùng đ vậy Hay là cái này C
pilot hay cái gì đó Cái này đều V trường
tôi thấy trả lời Mấy cái câu toàn liên
TH thuyề
Ờ Cho dù tôi vẫn đang muốn kiểu th hỏi
xem nó có thể ngon hơn được không Nói
chung là tôi đang muốn thử trải nghiệm
mọi cái thứ khác bởi Xem thế mạnh thừng
thằng ấy tính là trông có vẻ tiện mà Tôi
thấy thằng trả lời anh tinh nhất sợ so
với thằng C pilot bình thường hay là
thằng chity này
Ờ thằng ba thì à Ba rồi Chết rồi chỉ ch
miny ch miny thì tôi chưa được động vào
còn hôm nay như vừa mới Đề cập Vụ thằng
la đ thì rất là mới cloud à CL không
biết phát âm nhở đại khái là tôi nghĩ có
thời gian tôi sẽ thử tìm hiểu cái đấy
xem tình hình job it hiện tại Tuyển một
người mà hơn 50 người tuyển đâu Thực ra
là công ty tuyển vẫn có tuyển nhá Nhưng
mà gọi nh cái
cái trình độ các bạn bây giờ chưa đủ ý
nên là tuyển vào nó bị mệt ý Kiểu phải
mất thời gian đào tạo các th thứ và quan
trọng là nó liên quan đến thái độ làm
việc nữa chứ không phải về mỗi trình độ
nhá nế thành ra là kiểu nhiều nơi nó bị
ngại tuyển chứ thực ra là nếu các bạn
làm được việc và các bạn kiểu thích nghi
được môi trường nhanh thì công ty sẵn
sàng tuyển thêm bạn vì kiểu gì chẳng có
thể đem lại được hiệu quả Nhưng mà Đúng
là công ty Tôi ví dụ hôm trước thì sếp
tôi cũng bảo là bây giờ hiện tại đang ổn
định rồi và Việc thuê tuyển thêm một bạn
nữa thì phải cân nhắc đến bài toán kinh
doanh đó là bạn ấy về thì cái độ hiệu
quả Bạn ấy đem lại cái lợi ích bạn giá
trị bạn đem lại nó có nhiều hơn so với
việc là thuê bạn ấy không đúng không ạ
Nên là hiện tại anh em vẫn làm được việc
đấy các thứ đôi khi là tăng lương cho
anh em thêm một tí thôi anh em còn làm
việc xng sức hơn so việc mình tuyển hà
người mới đấy nên nên là nó bài toán
đánh đổi Nhưng mà nếu mà khi mà việc
căng quá kiểu anh em chỉ đến cái giới
hạn rồi thì sẽ tuyển thêm đấy thì nói
chung là vài công ty it luôn phải cân
nhắc việc đấy vì tính ra bây giờ kinh tế
cũng đang suy thoái các thứ thứ nên
thành ra nó cạnh tranh khá khốp liệt khó
khăn trong thời gian này thì chính các
bạn đang cạnh tranh nhau thì các bạn
phải làm thêm rất nhiều cái project
riêng tạo dấu ấn riêng chứ bây giờ đi
chỉ đi ứng tuyển ứng tuyển thì thấy
không hiệu quả
lắm
container
lên E eqs là cái
hình như là nó là elastic đúng rồi Tôi
nhớ là exs là viết tch của
altic container container nghe kiểu
container giao hàng ấ nhỉ
clae 3 được ứng dụng mạnh hơn nhưng mà
mình còn chưa biết được cụ thể nó mạnh
hơn mạnh hơn cả trong code nữa nhưng mà
chưa được động vào nên chưa
hỏi tôi phải chuno anh
chuno kênh tên là chuno chứ
Germany Germany Tôi còn ch chưa thử
chỉ tiêu mọi kỹ năng mọi level đấy thì
ai cũng sẽ phải từng trải qua FPT thôi
Tôi nghĩ là Thế qua đấy môi trường làm
việc cũng mình sẽ học được cái môi
trường làm việc chứ còn về kiến thức thì
tôi thấy là khó B đánh dám bởi vì nó còn
theo cái khả năng học của mỗi người và
gặp được đúng người gọi là cũng cũng sẵn
sàng chia sẻ thì mấy ông mới có thể học
hỏi
Ừ ông kia hỏi câu rất hay kìa Nếu bỏ ra
số tiền tương đương thì nên đăng ký
copilot hay gvt 4 C pilot thì tôi thấy
là được rất tốt hơn nhiều vì vì nó gợi ý
nhá liên tục tận răng
à các thứ các thứ và nói chung là kiểu
nó cũng thông minh nhưng nhưng ở đây lại
lại nhưng tí ví dụ ngay hiện tại là tôi
đang dùng cái extension miễn phí nó là
code I um
rất là
ổn cũng không không không thể nói là nó
ngon bằng copilot rồi nhá Nhưng mà nó
cũng rất là ổn thì ông dùng tiền đấy để
ông mua jpt bốn để mà hỏi thêm những cái
câu phức tạp như này xong rồi code ium
thì nó cũng đ nh là code ium của bả
à mất phí Nhưng mà tôi thấy là bản miễn
phí này dùng rất là ổn rồi cũng tương
tương đối đấy Tôi thấy ngon hơn cả thằng
Tab n Hồi trước tôi dùng
Ờ không biết là Tab n Bây giờ ngon hơn
chưa t n Hồi trước là ông anh cũng cho
xài cái cái premium của nó nhưng hồi đấy
là nó vẫn chưa có ai mạnh lắm
á Em thử tắt
đi mở lại thôi anh thấy nó vẫn gợi ý
nhưng mà nó không gợi ý Kiểu mạnh thôi
không gợi ý mạnh bằng cop log
code rồi các thứ thứ nhưng mà bây giờ
ông dùng một cái thằng ai cộng tương đối
miễn phí và những cái gì mà cảm thấy khó
phức tạp thì sử dụng chity thực ra là ừ
chat dvt như là chat DT 3 Nó cũng đủ
mạnh để trả lời cho ông khá nhiều cái
rồi nên là thành ra là nên là ông Cân
nhắc một trong hai dùng hẳn copilot cho
xịn cũng được Tôi dùng thằng Tôi dùng
qua thằng này công nhận là tôi cứ bị so
sánh với thằng
calot tục Ừ công ty tôi đầu tư cho cả
anh em cả CHT 4 và cot
à Không Đầu tư anh em à có đầu tư anh em
copilot anh em mua copilot thì công ty
vẫn sẽ hỗ trợ cho
này Nói chung là công ty tôi thì quan
tâm nhất về cái Lợi nhận các thứ à Phải
Lợi nhận à hiệu suất hiệu năng công việc
các thứ các thứ còn về bảo mật thì thực
ra là nói thẳng luôn là
là toàn bộ code mình không đến đế nỗi
ghê gớm đến thế mà cần phải bảo mật bản
chất là mình mạnh về việc là mình Tiên
Phong này cũng như có rất nhiều ý tưởng
các th thứ Ờ vân vân chứ không phải về
kiểu code các sự cần phải bảo mật lắm đế
thế không Tôi chưa trả phí cho code new
mà chắc là không ý định
tôi nghĩ ở trên cái nào cũng thế thôi mà
Đúng không cả pp Storm hay là vs code
này nó như nhau
hơn cho rồi tôi cũng chưa dùng
dùng không bị trùng tên test tầm 10
người Ấn cùng lúc thì không sao 50 người
update cùng lúc thì vẫn Trung tên
Ờ ông ông đầu tiên ông generate ra tên
hay là để người dùng nhập vào xong rồi
ông ngồi check Nếu mà như thế thì để
chắc chắn không trùng kiểu giống kiểu
username thì đươ nhiên mình đánh unic
cho cái đấy lẫn cả là trong code Tôi nhớ
hồi trước
là cái có cái thư viện của larel ấy đó
là kiểu lô lô check trước đó là cái đện
cài thêm thôi
kiểu như này đó là tức là sao Nghĩa là
nghĩa là khi mà trùng
ấy khi mà trùng nó sẽ luôn tôi nh nhớ nó
sẽ cộng luôn nó sẽ luôn kiểm tra xem
trùng hay chưa Nếu mà trùng rồi nó sẽ
cộng thêm một số nữa để chắc chắn nó sẽ
không
nà đây tôi sẽ đọc lướt th mà get slug
option generate form name này Đấy string
slug này này không đánh unic luôn không
biết là có chắc không đây nếu đây unic
lag xong rồi sẽ thêm một số nếu mà slug
Đấy tồn tại đấy ông thể dùng luôn cái
thư viện này để ông làm cho cái username
hoặc cái slug của ông để trannh không
trùng Thế trong trường hợp ông đang muốn
làm ch cái đấy còn nếu mà ông đang kiểm
tra theo name name mà không trùng nó hơi
bị vô lý đúng không
nào để có thể tự code Ý em là sao Kiểu
em cứ hay đọc mấy cái hướng dẫn các thứ
thứ em làm theo ấy thì thì tốt nhất là
cách kể thoát thì chỉ đơn giản em làm
những cái thứ mà chẳng có ai gợi ý cả
thì em sẽ phải tự học cách kiểu tự mò tự
làm xong rồi đấy có thể nhờ ai để nó gợi
ý các thứ một phần xong rồi mình tự nghĩ
tự làm
là cái tinh thần tự giác mình khó mình
vẫn còn bị ỷ lạ thì tất nhên là hãy làm
sao cho mình không thể ý lại được đúng
không
ạ Có vài ông hỏi về cái gerini tôi chưa
dùng ch mini luôn chưa dùng luôn
ấy N không làm tôi kiểu cũng to mò
quá nên tôi vẫn quay lại
hả đắt
này nó cài thêm mấy cái kiểu các thứ
tính năng này các thứ thứ nhưng mà 2T ở
trong tài khoản trái nghĩa gì với mình
cả cho dù tôi đang có
cái Google one
à Kiểu tôi có Ừ tôi có Google one 100 GB
Cũng chỉ đủ để mà kiểu làm những cái thứ
thứ thứ khác rồi có các tính năng của
benefit của One rồi n chả
cần đểm gì nh chưa
hiểu cái này phù hợp cho ông nào kiểu
cũng cần lưu chữ qua Google Drive nhiều
thích hợp
luôn mấy cái kiểu tích hợp vào mấy cái
này dog này tôi tôi có dùng mấy cái
Tôi không dùng hàm Microsoft nhiều nhá
tôi toàn kiểu lưu lại hết trên Drive để
mà dùng mình không thấy là tôi còn đang
cài thêm cả cái Google Drive này này
nghĩa tôi sẽ đồng bộ những cái tài liệu
ở trên máy
sẽ sẽ sẽ kiểu lập tức đồng bộ lên Drive
luôn nên là tôi có tôi thường ha dùng
doc và dùng slide của thằng Google chứ
không dùng của Microsoft à nhưng mà tôi
không cần tôi không nghĩ là tôi cần có
con ai trong đấy nhưng mà ừ nghe cũng vẻ
hay nghe cũng phải hay hay một cái gì đó
Nếu giả sử là nó tự động tạo kiểu mình
bị
lười mình mình bị lười kiểu dạng nhở
lười kiểu viết Slim lười sửa lại slime
mà thằng ai này mà hỗ trợ cho mình thì
nghe cũng nghe cũng xuôi tai nghe cũng
mượt mượt ấy nhỉ n bỏ người này tiền
ra Nó kiểu bị lãng phí Cái này là một
này Thứ hai là như nào nhỉ
dùng cái
mua cái này này ông có đấy tích hợp luôn
với năm người nữa cùng cái family của
ông tôi đang có bốn người trong Family
rồi nên là thật ra mấy người kia mà tận
dụng được cái mấy cái t này cũng được
nhưng mà mấy người đấy cũng không dùng
đế 100 GB Tôi đang dùng mấy người đ còn
chẳng dùng hết Google Photo nó khôn lắm
á Ừ tôi cũng không dùng google photo lắm
Hồi trước là tôi dùng google photo để
lưu ảnh G xh G sinh chọ lóc ấy nhưng mà
nhưng mà bây giờ tôi còn đang muốn tôi
nghĩ là nói chung là quay lại việc đấy
Dậy rồi các thứ thứ cũng không thời gian
đánh cho nó nữa tôi đang định Xóa hết
toàn bộ ảnh ấy đi thế này cũng chẳng có
lưu hay động vào các thứ thứ đấy
anh chị ơi đơ hết rồi Facebook chết nên
là tất cả mọi người chuyển qua nền tảng
khác nên là mấy cái khác chết thôi thằng
Zalo thì chắc là tôi nghĩ là thằng kiểu
ch server nó không hẳn xịn lắm khi mà
quá tải lượng người
dùng tiktok thì tôi không biết tiktok
5050 nhưng mà Đúng là đ đùng phát lên
thì
có thể không chịu được so với thằng
YouTube này thằng YouTube này tính ra
Tính ra là như nào nhỉ tính ra thằng
YouTube nó hàng của Google nó có hẳn
băng thông riêng của Google tôi nhớ là
vụ có vụ như thế hàng của Google là có
băng thông riêng cái tuyến đường cáp
riêng nên là thành ra là nó sẽ không
không bị chịu chung cái kiểu mấy cái kia
nên là Ừ bả sao lượng người lên đây xem
đông rồi rõ ràng mấy thằng kia chết thì
À mấy thằng kia ví dụ Facebook bị làm
sao đó thì thì mấy thằng kia nó có thể
bị kiểu bị Dồn một phát lượng người dùng
ấy thì có thể chết
vẫn là theo vốn hiểu biết của tôi có gì
sai mấy ông vẫn C ý sửa nhá Không thì
tôi lại kiểu giống như tôi không phải là
tôi không muốn mình thành thằng xí ngồi
đáy Dướng đâu
anh dùng m xong Anh cảm thấy quay lại
Win này nhiều cái tù thật à không phải
tù nó tiện hơn so với M M mới tù nhưng
mà làm chỉ m nó đúng kiểu mình bớt phải
nghĩ khi làm các thứ các thứ phải mất
công ngồi cài các thứ thứ mấy cái phím
tắt mọi thứ nó cũng tiện hơn thôi chưa
qua Tôi dùng U linus có đúng hồi mà học
ch để làm hacker th chứ cũng chưa tìm
hiểu sâu bên đấy nên cũng cũng chưa code
mọi thứ cài đạt trên đấy Nên khó đánh
giá nhưng mà tôi đánh giá Má sẽ một điểm
cộng khá lớn chẳng qua vì lý do đi dễ
học ngẫn cả Tôi muốn sử dụng song song
hệ điều hành nên là tôi mới C mới dùng
quein mới quay lại dùng tất cả những cái
đồ mà tôi vốn là không dùng
trước đây ví dụ Giả sử là vs code này
hay là window quay lại Win này hay thậm
chí là bây giờ tôi cài không cài tôi
không cài Cả code pilot dù tôi có tài
khoản mà tôi lại dùng code ium này chẳng
hạn để tôi muốn không phải muốn quen khổ
đâu mà nói chung là muốn thêm nhiều cái
góc nhìn
vấn ở trên mạng nó cũng chẳng tôi bảo
rồi tôi cũng chỉ người lại tôi khó mà tư
vấn chính xác các bạn và các bạn thường
ha bị bệnh về tâm lý bạn vượt qua được
cái tâm lý đấy thì các bạn mới làm được
việc
được bài tt Bài Test IQ khi làm ở công
ty khó không anh
Ừ tôi chưa làm bài test yqy giở ý ông là
hỏi mấy câu kiến thức về kiểu dạng là
thuật toán á thuật toán thì thì nó không
hẳn lại về y quy đâu Nó kiểu về hướng
giải quyết và lý thuyết các thứ là nhiều
hơn
nhá
nhả larel luôn không anh không em nên
làm cái thuần trước cho hiểu rõ bản chất
đã đừng có ham về công nghệ larel fw thì
nó vẫn là công nghệ Em phải hiểu về cái
thuần đã để em nhảy sang ngôn ngữ khác
tin đi Thức ra là tôi hạn chế như tôi
nói tôi hạn chế kiểu sử dụng não mình để
mà như kiểu ghi nhớ Mọi thứ cái gì mà
mình cảm thấy là nó kiểu cần phải nhớ
thì mình thường kiểu nốt lại mình ghi
chú lại đu
đó tổng hợp thì họ như này đươ nhiên là
mình sẽ phải đầu tiên mình tôi nghĩa là
cách học của tôi nói chung đi thì khi mà
tôi học một cái gì đó tôi sẽ phải Ừ phải
làm quen phải thích nghi dần phải tìm
hiểu về nó để sao cho mình cảm thấy là
mình có góc nhìn khái quát và mình cũng
phải thích thích nó thì mình mới học
được còn nếu mà không thì không thích nó
đúng là rất là khó để mà học một cái gì
đó và tôi khi mà tôi học nó thứ nhất là
nghiêm túc với nó thứ hai tôi không Tôi
không nghĩ nhiều về việc là tại sao mình
học nó hay là bị áp lực về việc học đâu
vì tôi cảm thấy là tôi cần nó nên tôi
muốn tìm hiểu về nó thôi chứ tôi không
suy nghĩ việc là tôi đang học một cái gì
đó không Tôi không nghĩ việc
đấy em đi phỏng vấn mà nhà Tuyển dụng
yêu cầu tiếng Anh giao tiếp Thành Thảo
mà em bị tạch từ thì không biết cải
thiện tiếng Anh như
nào cải thiện tiếng Anh như nào thì ra
là các bạn kiểu học ở trung tâm để cải
thiện tiếng Anh vân vân Nếu mà các bạn à
tinh thần tự tự giác tự lập không tốt mà
như tôi vừa nói cũng nhắc V việc học thì
á chỉ ông sẽ phải kiểu cũng thích qua ví
dụ học một ngôn ngữ nào đó hay học một
cái gì đó Phả thích thích qua nó thích
văn hóa tìm hiểu qua văn hóa của nó đã
mình sẽ dễ tiếp xúc với nó hơn chứ đừng
có cứ kiểu dạng là học lý thuyết học đủ
lý thuyết đọc rất nhiều sách thừ thứ Tôi
nghĩ là không phải ai cũng phù hợp với
kiểu học đấy
triển tôi nghĩa tôi phải bỏ qua mấy câu
này vì tôi không hề
biết không biết trả lời mấy câu đấy xin
chịu
ạ anh còn tiếp tục khóa auto it không
không anh không Cái đấy là của anh Juno
rồi
không Không tôi gần đây tôi có tìm hiểu
về chứng chỉ Quỹ cũng muốn thử đầu tư
một cái gì đó Tôi không muốn tìm tôi
không muốn đầu tư vào một cái gì đó quá
mạo hiểm giống như là tiền Hảo hay cái
thứ
bơ vơ khó dùng khi mà em dùng một thời
gian rồi em sẽ thấy ma nó tiện hơn Win
rất rất nhiều
Ờ nhưng mà đương nhiên là trên lớp hay
trên l các thứ thì anh vẫn khuyên em nên
dùng Win Nếu có thể bởi vì các thầy mọi
thầy vẫn thường ha Hướng dẫn bằng Win
thì các bạn dễ tiếp cận dễ hiểu hơn lúc
đấy Mọi thứ đều mới với mình mà đúng
không
Meta sập m
Ờ nếu có thể anh có thể xare C vi của
mình được không ạ Ờ Thực ra tôi có chia
sẻ CV của tôi ở trên trang C nhân ấy thì
mấy ông có thể kiểu xem lại thực ra là
CV tôi cũng chẳng có gì đâu và lâu lắm r
tôi không cập nhật thì không có gì để
khoe cả
lấy cái này từ bin gợi ý đấy thì thậm
chí là tôi qua cái này tôi còn dùng s
chứ không phải dùng Chrome nữa này xong
rồi dùng Bin chứ không phải dùng Google
nữa này để nói chung là tôi thêm thêm
rất nhiều góp nhìn và thêm nhiều trải
nghiệm cũng kiểu thêm một cái
hay cho dù tôi cảm thấy nhiều lúc tôi
phải quay lại dùng Google để mà tra tìm
kiếm vì thằng này nó cứ đôi khi nó không
ra được kết quả mình muốn
code Z mết anh à Thế bây giờ vẫn còn
code Z tôi bắt đầu phải cân nhắc v cái
công ty đấy một một là công ty đấy Kiểu
bảo thủ hai công ty đấy cũng khá là lỗi
thời khi kiểu thậm chí là phải duy trì
mấy cái dự án lỗi thời chứ không được
codt những cái tính năng mới nó cũng rất
là trở ngại các thứ thì trong việc học
của mình vì rõ ràng mình học mấy cái đấy
mình ra ngoài mình sang công ty khác nó
áp dụng công nghệ khác mình cũng bị tù
ấy nên là tôi cảm thấy
là làm Học được cái gì học sau đó thì
cũng té sớm khi mà những công ty mà bị
kiểu bảo thủ dùng những công nghệ cũ anh
đánh giá con bot ai nào Ổn nhất hiện tại
thì phục vụ trong việc code thì tôi vẫn
thấy là cot thôi vì tôi chưa dùng mấy
thằng khác cũng chưa tích hợp đấy Hôm
nay tích hợp mỗi code mium thì tôi đã
đánh giá không cao rồi thằng chity thì
nó vẫn chỉ dừng mức tương đối hỏi đáp
chứ không phải là code kiểu dạng
là gợi ý code Trần chỉ được mình vẫn
phải sửa và mình phải trên cho nó liên
tục
à ch Min thì chưa được dùng này ba thì
đểu này Ờ cloude cũng chưa dùng này hết
rồi Uầy Hôm nay cũng livestream được khá
nhiều rồi tạm thời trả lời được tương
đối có gì thì Ừ chắc là buổi sau
tôi buổi sau tôi
sẽi chia sẻ hết đống l nốt ạ Cứ định
kiểu chia sẻ thế này Cuối cùng thì một
buổi chỉ là ngồi trả lời chá đã hết sử
thời gian rồi anh dùng
wsl hình như là cái này là liên quan
docker mà đúng không Tôi nhớ Tôi có dùng
cái
này Windows service gì đấy
dùng cái này để chạy docker
không Tôi anh Mạnh Tuấn Anh ấy dạy khóa
auto it mà không phải tôi
Server thì mới chạy đu
nhưng mà tôi còn phải ăn đã đã ăn tối
đâu
Ờ ăn tối đã rồi chắc là lúc đấy Facebook
lên là vừa không thì mình sẽ ngồi lướt
Facebook à nhầ lướt tiktok với
đâu hả anh Nếu không lưu trong dB
thường là tôi tôi lưu sẽ có thể lưu qua
cooki cũng được vì rõ ràng nó không phải
là cái gì đó quá phức tạp để à không
phải quá bảo mật nhạy cảm đương nhiên là
nhảy sang tài khoản à nhảy sang máy khác
thì nó sẽ mới mất vài nơi kiểu kiểu như
thế l coki
à đấy local Stories
ấy đấy
lại chỗ zion đấy vào trong a
à lưu lại chỗ zion đấy vào trong kiểu DB
thôi chứ cũng
họ
nhờ còn không lưu local Stories Tôi nghĩ
là hai giải pháp đấy
thôi có bị vấn đề về bao tử không Ừ tôi
chưa bị nhưng mà chắc có thể nếu mà ăn
uống C thất thường Nên là chắc là tạm
tạm ngừng ở đây nhá ui m không Hỏi nhiều
quá Tôi xin phép là những câu hỏi nào mà
chưa trả lời được thì buổi sau mấy ông
hỏi lại hộ tôi nhá Không hôm nay không
thể ngồi trả lời hết được còn chưa ăn
uống gì cả
ờ out có nên lưu vào Token không á cũng
được Em Token mình mã hóa theo cách của
mình chắc cũng không dịch ra được đâu
thế